بالجمال والبياض من قمه جبل اللوز ينضم
الينا مراسل صباح العربيه هاني صفيان هاني
يسعد صباحك اهلا بك موجه ثالثه
ثلجيه ولو خفيفه للمره الثالثه على قمه
جبل اللوز تفاصيل معك هذه
انا بس قبل ما ابدا يعني انا عندي عتب على
نادين يعني تخلص من العلا ولا تيجي اليوم
يعني ترى ترى المسافه كلها 200 كيلو يعني
الثلج همم
زملائنا في مكتب الريف كانوا تمنوا ان
اكون هاني في كل مره
[ضحك]
يشرفني بالعكس انا بس بودي لك تجيني
تعيشين الاجواء الجميله والصوره الجميله
خاصه مع التقنيات والامكانيات يعني
الموجوده عند العربيه الان عندنا الكاميرا
الجاهدونا والكاميرا الثانيه الجويه اللي
تلتقط قمم جبل اللوز والثلوج جبل اللوز في
الموجه الثالثه نعم هي يعني قد تكون موجود
تساقط الثلوج خفيفه ولكن همم
الجو جميل الهوى صافي درجه حرارتها لمس
الصفر لكن الصفر الناعم يعني مش صفر
البارد فعلا
وكذلك ايضا الاجواء يعني هذه مره مختلفه
خاصه من السياح والزوار يعني في الموجه
الاولى شاهد
كميه الثلوج الموجه الثانيه فالان تحمسوني
يجون
ويصلون الى هذه المنطقه
همم قمه جبل اللوز في نيو
المشاهدين ليش احنا اهتمين في جبل اللوز
انه فكره موجود عليه ثلوج لانه هذا المشهد
يعني هو يعتبر مثلا مشهد قليل انه مقارنه
مع بلاد فيها ثلج كثير كبير وبيطلع بصير
الثلج واصل لطول البني ادم ليش اليوم جبل
اللوز امر لافت انه يكون فيه ثلج يعني
يقول لغير السعوديين ولا المشاهدين يعني
يا ريت طيب انا انا رحت اتحدث عن هذا
الامر فعلا هو امر مهم والسؤال مهم يعني
انه ما راح اتحدث فقط عن قمه جبل اللوز
راح اتحدث عن منطقه نيوم والمناطق اللي
تكون او تتساقط فيها الثلوج اما الجبل
اللي له تحديدا لان التضاريس فيها جميله
الجبال وطبيعتها جدا جميله لما يتساقط
الثلج ويتشكل الثلج على هذه القمه يطلع
شيء خرافي نعم قد تكون الصوره زي ما وضحت
انه تساقط الثلوج هالمره خفيف لكن عند لما
يتساقط بشكل كبير يطلع بشكل اخر ومختلف
طبعا في منطقه اليوم ايضا في تساقط الثلوج
لكن
ااا المعجم ما وصلتها في هذه المناطق مثل
المنطقه اسمها الظهر والزيتا وكذلك على
جان ولكن لم تشهد تساقط الثلوج مثل هذه
المنطقه وهذه المنطقه تحديدا يفضلها
الزوار والسياح غير انه موضوع ثلوج ايضا
موضوع ممارسه الهايكينج فما بالك انه
يمارسون الهايكنج مع تساقط الثلوج مع
الطبيعه الجميله مع مشاريع نيوم اللي ان
تقوم بعملها فهذه جميعا هي موجوده في هذه
الطبيعه بشكل عام اهتمام السعوديه
بالسياحه في المنطقه
يعني اللغه الانجليزيه
في ناس جايين هنغاري وهذا اللي صدمني يعني
قلت
قالوا نعم ان سمعنا وشفنا وكنا مارين
راحوا العلا كانوا في العلا قالوا بمن
قريبين وسمعنا عن الموجه الثلج طبعا ايه
قالوا خلينا نروح كلها مسافه تقريبا
ساعتين ونصف يعني طبعا في امر اخر بس من
ناخذ الجانب الاخر علشان احنا نواكب عمليه
تساقط الثلوج ان طبعا كنا موجودين من امس
من العصر وكان عندنا خيمه بسيطه خيمتي
الحياه المعيشيه في هذا الامر وهذه من
الحياه السعاده الجميله همم غير طبعا شبت
النار عبر المنقل همم
للحفاظ على البيئه وكذلك الجو الجميل في
هذه المنطقه اللي همم تشهدها نيوم تحديدا
تم الجبل اللوز او المناطق الاخرى التي
ذكرتها مثل الظهر وعلى كان والزيتا
وايضا ال- ال- همم
الظهر والزيت وعلى نعم صحيح
مستقبليه في هذه المنطقه اما في جبل اللوز
وامتدادا ايضا الى نيوم شكرا